bonsoir schalwyk mot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on
commencera par ce scrutin dont on
parlait qui se tient ce mardi aux
etats-unis et qui doit décider de la
majorité au sénat un scrutin ont combien
décisif sur le mandat de joe biden
[Musique]
effectivement c'est décisif pour le
congrès le sénat va-t-il rester
républicain ou va-t-il devenir dom au
crac
traditionnellement la georgie et
républicaine et le fait que joe biden a
remporté aisément ajouter tout le monde
les démocrates ne tente pas à voter lors
des élections au secondaire donc c'est
vraiment un mystère et les démocrates
ont même tendance à bénéficier du vote
anticipé et il y en a eu pour cette
sélection depuis plusieurs semaines dont
il fait montre à son avantage mais il
les résultats sont encore incertains le
sénateur républicain ils vont qu'il est
risqué un poste où les démocrates
vont-ils emporté alors concrètement ça
voudrait dire quoique notamment la
réforme de l'assurance-santé ses
ambitions à joe biden en matière
d'environnement ou encore son projet de
contrôle des armes à feu pourrait être
bloqué par les républiques de
républicains s'il n'obtenait pas la
majorité démocrate
demanda au niveau du congrès ou des
politiques nationales
la victoire de joe biden est suspecte la
moitié du il pense qu'il ya eu de la
fraude
ils ont perdu beaucoup de sièges dans la
chambre des représentants ce qui a
choqué tout le monde on s'attendait
vraiment
les actuaires encore d'autres sièges
c'est un fait il manque maintenant une
très courte majorité
si les républicains maintiennent le
contrôle du sénat alors cela va rendre
les choses très compliquées
en tout cas le premier mandant de baden
et de kamala harris
donc il va s'agir d'une résidence sont
très entraves et sans doute essayer de
s'en rappeler autant de défaites
personnes m'apprécient jeu bayonne on ne
le connaît pas vraiment je sais que
c'est un genre de néo libérale à la
toute jeune kamala harris ne serait pas
un peu plus radicale mais aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il va réussir beaucoup de
grandes choses cours de sa présidence si
le scénariste et républicains en france
il est de tradition souvent de donner la
majorité au président nouvellement élu à
l'assemblée pour voilà tout simplement
valider une nouvelle fois ce vote pour
qu'il puisse agir et appliquer son
programme
le fait justement que cette victoire ne
soit pas si acquises ou qu'ils aient une
courte majorité qu'est ce que ça dit que
le pays est encore finalement très
divisé et bien sûr et très divisés mais
ça c'est le système américain seraient
les freins et les contre-pouvoirs dans
le bénéficions pouvoirs du président et
a limité par le concret je baille dame
n'est pas très populaire c'est vraiment
le vote anti tron qui l'a fait élire
certaines personnes bien qu'étant
républicains pour beaucoup de personnes
ont voté contre on est président mais
pour les républicains à d'autres niveaux
de pouvoir
beaucoup de personnes disent nous
n'avions pas connu la crise mais il vous
manque pas non
démocrates qui sont ils ont choqué afin
qu'il y ait des phrases qu'on peut le
pouvoir du président il ya beaucoup de
gars savent qu'ils n'ont pas découvert
moment où aimerait bien qu'il y ait un
ex-aequo au c'est moi qui le rendent
incapables d'agir
le programme démocrate et le politicien
démocrate sont très radicaux il pourrait
mettre en oeuvre des politiques
radicales au niveau de l'assurance santé
mais également au niveau du goût du
système tout entier au niveau du voc
certains démocrates se débarrasser du
collège électoral va changer la
constitution veulent s'attaquer au
premier et au deuxième amendement vous
plaît à un texte fondateur de notre
cause et beaucoup de personnes refuse
cela avant qu'ils aient encore des
freins et des contre-pouvoirs
alors on l'a vu un donateur lui continue
de clamer que la victoire lui a été volé
il a fait pression sur le secrétaire
d'état de géorgie pour qu'ils lui
trouvent ces fameuses bulletins de vote
qui manquait les presque 2000 comment
réagit le camp républicain à cette vidéo
un petit peu embarrassante tout de même
la façon dont elle a présenté et a très
embarrassante
il faut savoir que son album tout invité
de larqué qui a été mise en ligne par le
washington post
et on dirait que le pilote de l'un d'eux
se regarde est un peu le créa tebbutt
mais si l'on étouffe toute la
conversation il est des avocats des deux
côtés ce n'est pas tout à fait cela
donald trump demande au secrétaire
d'état si vous connaissez accusations
défaut de souley connaissez vidéos de
personnes qui essayent de truqué le vote
toutes ces vidéos qui sont présentés
dans les médias et le secrétaire d'état
elle semble presque fou il semble que
naïve elle semble être au courant de
rien et il est très facile de faire des
montages qui me semble le faire parler
le président lui maintenir très
compétente
ils étaient francs ils ne choisissent
pas forcément bien ses mots cela n'est
pas ce qui ressort de la vidéo dans sa
totalité le donnant votre secrétaire
d'état de commettre un crime mais bien
sur les réseaux sociaux les technocrates
prétendent que c'est le cas que tonna
propres essais de l'inciter au crime
mais ce n'était pas la teneur de la
conversation rapidement dernière
question à quoi doit-on s'attendre pour
le 20 janvier quelle sera la stratégie
de donald trump pour les prochaines
semaines citant les gens qui pensent que
c'est impossible
l'éléphant dans le magasin de porcelaine
des politiques agricoles il a changé le
parti républicain et je ne pense pas que
le parti de revenir en arrière je pense
que de notre homme va rester une force
très importante sur la campagne de 2024
pourrait cautionner des candidats très
important soit changer le parti tient
maintenant ils sont partis ils ont même
si joe biden devient président alors
dans la drogue qui va pas s'évaporer
certains américains ne sont pas partant
pour le programme trucks et eux vont
devoir se justifier
lorsque ils vont être en campagne face à
des personnes soutenues par donald trump
merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous pour vu de l'extérieur
shadwick moore merci à vous